[Music]  it's good to take your shoes off and  walk in the grass when it's Paltrow  admits even she is sometimes confused by  her lifestyle brand goop you go like oh  that seems a little bit oh yeah yeah the  hilarious moment went down on Mondays  Jimmy Kimmel Live the late-night host  had a few questions about the things  he's seen on the group website like the  Jade egg so the Jade egg is an ancient  Chinese practice where women insert the  Jade egg in their ladies part right and  to help tone the pelvic floor how does  it help do that I don't know I need to  start no JD wanna the total health and  fitness enthusiast also got candid about  some not so healthy habits here's what  happened when Jimmy and Gwen it's talked  about her teenage years at sleepaway  camp not like a good place to learn how  to smoke my first timer right when I was  13 I think I came back like a pack of  Camel Lights a day  [Music]  you